Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Pretlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 108. Ausgabe von Raumzeit.
Und ja, was haben wir hier nicht schon viel Zeit verbracht bei Raumzeit auf
die deutsche und die europäische Raumfahrt und alle wissenschaftlichen Aktivitäten,
die damit verbunden sind, zu blicken.
Und heute will ich den Blick mal ein wenig erweitern auf den Elefanten im Raum.
Nämlich die NASA, die eigentlich ja überall drin steckt und letzten Endes auch
angefangen hat und ja dazu freue ich mich sehr meinen Gesprächspartner begrüßen
zu können, nämlich Thomas. Thomas Zurbuchen. Hallo, herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit.
Ja, das freut mich sehr, dass es geklappt hat. Ja, Thomas, Tour buchen oder
soll man sagen 289116 Tour buchen.
Gibt nicht so viele Leute, nach denen ein Astrologerie benannt wurde,
aber dir ist die Ehre zuteil geworden.
Hat auch einen Grund, weil du bist ganz lange schon im Geschäft und ja,
Physiker, nicht wahr, Physik studiert und dann, glaube ich, als Astrophysiker
im Wesentlichen spezialisiert.
Genau und dann später auch Professor für Space Science geworden an der University
of Michigan und dann mündete das Ganze
in eine gut achtjährige Zeit als Wissenschaftsdirektor eben bei der NASA.
Oder wie das so schön heisst, Associate Administrator for the Science Mission
Directorate. Komplizierter Name. Was heisst das genau?
NASA hat im Wesentlichen vier Teile, die zusammenarbeiten. Der erste Teil,
der natürlich sehr bekannt ist und ganz am Anfang von NASA stand,
ist die Raumfahrt mit Menschen.
Also mit Astronautinnen und Astronauten, die in den Raum gehen.
Das zweite für ungefähr ein Drittel des ganzen Budgets ist die Wissenschaft.
Es ist wirklich alle Wissenschaft von der Erde.
Nicht nur Satelliten, die Forschung machen, zusammen mit internationalen Partnern
oft, sondern auch die Satelliten, die die Wettervoraussagen auf der Ost- und
Westküste geostationären, in Amerika.
Aber auch Low-Earth-Orbit-Satelliten, die auch in Europa gebraucht werden.
Satelliten auch hier in Deutschland oder in Europa werden die Daten von amerikanischen Satelliten gebraucht.
Von dort, von der Erde bis ins tiefe Universum, wo zum Beispiel das James Webb
Space Telescope im Moment sich das tiefe Universum ansieht.
Und alles dazwischen, auch die Voyager-Missionen, die ich in meiner ganzen Kindheit
begleitet habe, und dann Missionen auf dem Mars und vielen anderen Planeten.
Also man ist sozusagen für alles zuständig. Mädchen für alles.
Ja genau, das ist die Wissenschaft. Die zwei anderen Teile übrigens sind Space Tech,
also wirklich auf Technologie fokussiert und der erste bei NASA ist der Aeronautics,
also wirklich auf die Technologie der Flugzeuge und Technologie für den Luftraum, nicht den Meltdown.
Bevor wir dann richtig auf die NASA zu sprechen kommen, würde mich natürlich
noch mal interessieren, wie es denn überhaupt dazu kam. Wie hast du diesen Weg dorthin gefunden?
Wie findet man so einen Job?
Also man hört es bei meinem Akzent. Ich habe einen Akzent in jeder Sprache,
inklusive Deutsch, weil ich in der Schweiz aufgewachsen bin.
Und was wirklich speziell ist an NASA, und du hast es schon vorher gesagt,
wir arbeiten oft mit Europa zusammen und so weiter,
Aber ganz am Anfang, bei Apollo 11, als die zwei auf den Mond gingen,
und Armstrong das erste wissenschaftliche Experiment aufgesetzt hat,
ein Schweizer Experiment.
Das war eine Folie, eine Schokoladefolie aus Aluminium, einfach viel teurer und viel reiner.
Diese Folie wurde ganz einfach von Basaldron aufgespannt. Übrigens habe ich
Basaldron diese Woche getroffen.
Er ist jetzt 93 Jahre alt und hat das aufgestellt und Sonnenwinde eingesammelt.
Ausserhalb der Magnetosphäre, der magnetischen Schutzschild der Erde.
Sonnenmaterial wurde dort gesammelt und zurück auf die Erde gebracht.
Das war der Anfang des Institutes, wo ich gearbeitet habe. Und darum habe ich dort gelernt.
Instrumente zu bauen für die ESA, aber auch mein erstes Instrument,
das ich gebaut habe. Ich bin immer noch sehr stolz darauf, es fliegt immer noch
bei der NASA. Es ist ein Teil des Satellitenwinds, der eben den Sonnenwind beobachtet.
Ich habe diese Erfahrung dort gesammelt und übrigens auch in Deutschland gearbeitet,
mit Göttingen, mit Freiburg und so weiter, in meiner ganzen Diplomzeit.
Dann ging ich nach Amerika und baute eine Gruppe auf, in der wir Satelliteninstrumente gebaut haben.
Ich unterrichtete, wie man das tut. Space Systems ist der amerikanische Art
und Weise, darüber zu sprechen.
Wie man Systeme baut. Viele meiner Studierenden sind Führer in der Industrie, auch bei SpaceX.
Der Mann, der zuständig ist für die ganze ... Der Vice President for Launch.
All diese Launches, die ganze Infrastruktur, inklusive der Schiffe,
ist mein früherer Student, Kiko heisst er.
Als wir das James-Webb-Spacetelescope aufgefaltet haben, wurde jede zweite Schicht
in der Nacht von einem anderen Studenten von mir geführt.
Als wir dort in den Asteroiden reingefahren haben, war die Frau am Mikrofon,
die alle sahen, eine andere Studentin.
Ich habe in Michigan auch ein Innovationssystem aufgebaut, insbesondere auch
mit Raum. Das war eines der ersten.
Dann kam NASA und sagte, wir brauchen eine Person, die für Wissenschaft zuständig
ist. Ich hatte die Erfahrung als Wissenschaftler in Engineering,
also wie man das auch baut.
Und dann das dritte, ich habe Erfahrungen gesammelt über Start-ups,
wie funktioniert New Space.
Wie geht das? Ich war einer der Ersten, der so ein Editorial herausgeschrieben
hat, der hat gesagt, SpaceX kann erfolgreich sein, obwohl das sehr kontrovers
war. Viele haben gesagt, es sei ein Akademiker, der nichts weiss.
Die hatten wahrscheinlich recht, übrigens. Aber die Tatsache ist,
NASA hat mich gefragt, darum ging ich dorthin und war der längste Direktor der
Wissenschaft in NASA seit der Geschichte der Agentur.
Die Rolle ist jetzt nicht neu geschaffen worden, die gab es schon vorher?
Die gab es schon vorher. Ganz von Anfang an wurde das gebaut bei der NASA.
Die Rolle ist ziemlich intensiv. Die Associate Administrator ist wirklich eine
Stufe unter dem Chef, zuständig für, wie gesagt, ein Drittel der Agentur.
Und was das heisst, ist so die Unterschrift, die zählt. Also mit anderen Worten,
ich habe immer gesagt, He who testifies makes the final decision.
Also der, der im Kongress dann sitzen muss und verteidigen muss,
was wir gemacht haben, das bin ich.
Ich mache die Entscheidung und jede Entscheidung, ob man bereit ist zu launchen,
welche Mission man baut, jede Stufe in der Entwicklung, das war mein Job.
Bis vor kurzem, ich habe es gerade abgegeben, Ende Jahr.
Acht Jahre waren das jetzt?
Ein wenig, 6,5 Jahre Vollzeit im Job. 6,5, ah ok.
Immerhin eine Menge Zeit, da hat man auch eine Menge gesehen.
Was muss man für ein Verhältnis aufbauen zum Apparat und seinen Mitarbeitern,
um diesen Trust Level dann auch zu erreichen, weil den braucht man ja letzten
Endes, wenn man irgendwie die letzte Entscheidung hat, bedeutet das ja,
man muss ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, dass all das, was einem an Informationen
zugetragen wird, man kann das ja nicht alles.
Selber überprüfen, dass das auch passt, dass dieser ganze Apparat,
dieser gesamte Überprüfungsmechanismus gut funktioniert.
Muss der groß organisiert werden?
Läuft das von alleine? Ist das so ein permanenter Verbesserungsmodus?
Ist man damit im Wesentlichen beschäftigt? Oder was macht sozusagen diese Rolle im Wesentlichen aus?
Also es gibt zwei Teile davon. Das erste ist so operationell,
also wie macht man entscheiden?
Das andere ist die strategische Seite. Also sprechen wir mal über die Operationelle.
Also es ist ein System aufgebaut worden in der NASA, die wirklich gebaut ist,
sodass man Entscheidungen mit Risiko schafft.
Das wird so aufgeräumt. Es gibt ein System, das anfängt mit den Ingenieuren
und Techniken, die ihre Pläne mit Managern erarbeiten.
Die kommen zu einer Stufe, zum Beispiel in der Astrophysik, in der Division.
Die Astrophysiker sind zuständig und dann kommt es zu mir.
Und wenn die zu mir kommen, als Chef der Wissenschaft, wenn die zu mir kommen
für eine Entscheidung, eine neue Mission oder weiterzugehen,
hat es viele Meinungen im Raum.
Ganz bewusst wird die Entscheidung verteilt.
Am Schluss gibt es nur eine Stimme, die zählt, meine. Es ist nicht so,
dass am Schluss gemittelt wird.
Aber das Ganze ist so aufgebaut, dass man ganz bewusst versucht,
verschiedene Ansichten in den Raum zu bekommen.
Und zum Beispiel die Manager, die sicherstellen, dass alles sauber ist.
Also alles perfekt, ich weiss, was ich tue, ich laufe auf Wasser und so.
Alles, alles, alles perfekt. Aber dann haben wir eine unabhängige Gruppe,
die für mich arbeitet und wirklich technisch tief schaut, geht das.
Tief schaut mit nur Engineering. Also wirklich sind alle Lösungen gebraucht worden. Die Top-Notch.
Es gibt Dinge, die wir in anderen Missionen wissen, von denen Sie lernen müssen.
Und dann am Schluss im Raum ist zum Beispiel der Astrophysikchef,
aber auch der Erdwissenschaftschef und der Heliophysiker, Planetologie.
Und die helfen auch. Und ich habe noch einmal einen Direktor zuständig für Safety,
einen Direktor zuständig für Engineering.
Wir probieren aktiv, die Projekte zu röntgen. Und das richtet sich dazu,
ist constant improvement.
Also wirklich so am Anfang, als ich dorthin kam, hatte ich das Problem,
dass oft die Leute gar nicht aufgepasst hatten.
Also Leute haben E-Mails gemacht und so weiter. Und ich habe gesagt,
ich will, dass jede Person, die in diesem Raum ist, am Anfang alles schon gelesen hat.
Also ich will, dass die meiste Zeit im Raum Diskussion ist.
Nicht irgendwie Glanz und Gloria Präsentation.
Und jede Mission hat Risiken. Ich will verstehen, was die Risiken sind.
Ich will nicht, wenn jemand zu mir kommt und sagt, es gibt keine Risiken,
das heisst, dass sie nicht arbeiten. Also die schicke ich zurück.
Jede Mission hat Risiken. Ich will wissen, was die sind. Und wir wollen darüber sprechen.
Das ist eines der schönsten.
Die Wissenschaft ist unglaublich schön. Diese Systeme, die gebaut werden,
sind unglaublich imposant und schön zu sehen, wie die funktionieren.
Aber das andere wirklich Schöne ist, die Schönheit eines Teams, dass es funktioniert.
Wenn man wirklich die Leute... Keine Idee ist heilig.
Jede Idee wird angegriffen. Das ist ganz normal.
Die Leute in meiner, also mein Team war legendär in der NASA.
Immer noch, weil das Team funktioniert genauso weiterhin.
Aber jede Idee wird angegriffen. Jeder, der zu uns kam, der sagte,
pass auf, jede Idee wird angegriffen.
Und der Grund dafür ist, wie in der Wissenschaft, man glaubt an die Wissenschaft
nicht, wie ein Gläubiger oder so, sondern weil man eine wissenschaftliche Tatsache ...
Man versucht, alles zu töten. Und am Schluss lebt sie immer noch.
Jeden Moment irgendwie Hämmer und Gewehre und alles. Man will diese wissenschaftliche
Tatsache kaputt machen. Man testet sie, was man immer tut.
Man ... ... tut sie unter Druck. Und am Schluss ist sie immer noch dort,
diese Tatsache. Darum hat man Vertrauen. Das Gleiche ist der Fall in diesen Entscheidungen.
Das ist so die operationale Art und Weise, wie ein intensives Team,
wo wirklich Ideen hin- und hergeworfen
werden und am Schluss man zu einer Entscheidung kommt, ja oder nein.
Jetzt würde mich mal interessieren, wenn man das mal so ein bisschen aufbricht
und sagen wir mal es beginnt jetzt,
Missionen dauern ja immer sehr lange, also das ist ja von der ersten Idee bis
es dann wirklich zum Start und zum Abschluss einer Mission kommt,
je nachdem worum es geht, reden wir ja mindestens über 10 Jahre,
wenn nicht sogar sehr viel länger.
Aber du wirst ja in der Zeit sozusagen eigentlich mit allen Phasen irgendeines
Projektes mal Kontakt gehabt haben.
Wenn man mal so an den Anfang geht, wenn so die erste Entscheidung gefällt wird,
dann ist es ja zunächst einmal wirklich auch ein wissenschaftliches Abwägen,
wo wollen wir eigentlich hin?
Was wollen wir eigentlich wissen und was denken wir, was wir auch an Wissen
generieren können mit den Mitteln und Möglichkeiten, die uns zur Verfügung stehen?
Was ist das für ein Prozess, wo fängt das an und wo schlägt das auch das erste
Mal bei der NASA auf und wie geht man damit um?
Um das mal herauszufinden, was machen wir eigentlich wirklich?
Das ist eine wirklich gute Frage. Bevor man über die erste Mission spricht,
passiert ein Prozess, der unabhängig ist von der NASA.
Und es ist unglaublich wichtig, dass er unabhängig ist. Es ist ein Prozess,
der zu tun hat mit den National Academies, mit der Akademie.
Das sind die besten Wissenschaftler in Amerika, haben auch internationale Mitglieder, die mithelfen.
Sie kommen alle zehn Jahre in jedem Gebiet, Astrophysik, Erdwissenschaft,
und fragen, was die wichtigste Wissenschaft in diesen zehn Jahren ist.
Sie schreiben einen Report, eine Strategie.
Sie sagen, von allen Dingen, die man tun könnte, planetare Wissenschaft zum
Beispiel, ist das Wichtigste, das Erste, dass wir Proben von Mars zurückbringen.
Das Zweitwichtigste ist, dass wir diese Planeten aussen, Uranus und Neptun, besuchen.
Wir haben seit Voyager die nicht mehr gesehen.
Wir kennen so viele Planeten überall in unserer Galaxie, die so aussehen wie
diese Planeten. Wir haben sie nicht gesehen.
Deshalb ist Uranus die zweite Priorität und die dritte Priorität für grosse
Missionen ist zum Enceladus zurückzugehen.
Dieser Mond, dieser verrückte Mond.
Mit den Eisgeissieren.
Mit den Eisgeissieren. Das sind die Prioritäten und das hilft unglaublich.
Also bevor jemand etwas tut bei der NASA, wissen wir, hier sind die Prioritäten.
Wir wollen nicht ein System, wo der Chef der NASA die Strategie setzt.
Ich will, dass wir die beste Wissenschaft tun.
Wer auch immer der Chef ist. Wenn ich es bin, dann ich. Wenn es jemand anderes ist, dann die.
Und die Akademie ist jetzt...
Separat von der NASA. Absolut.
Und ich habe nichts damit zu tun, als Chef der NASA, als Chef der Wissenschaft
bei der NASA, außer dass ich dafür bezahle.
Und dann kommt diese Review und dann bauen wir eine Strategie drauf.
Die höchsten Prioritäten, Planetologie, das sind die Prioritäten für die nächsten zehn Jahre.
Ich wollte gerade fragen, ob das jetzt nur dahergesagt wurde.
Nein, nein, das sind absolut die Prioritäten.
Das freut mich sehr mit dem Uranus. Ich habe mich schon immer gefragt,
warum wir da noch nicht ...
Genau, das sind die Prioritäten. Und dann in dieser Strategie heisst es auch,
wir sollen kleinere Missionen machen in der Umgebung des Innensonnensystems.
Und auch zu anderen Orten gehen. Es gibt eine Liste von sechs Orten, wo wir hin sollen.
Zum Beispiel gehen wir zu Mio. Wir sollen auf dem Mond eine Seismologienetwork bauen.
Das sind nicht die grössten Missionen, sondern zweite Grösse.
Dann gehen wir raus zu der Community und fragen, was die besten Ideen für das sind.
Und jetzt kommen sie zu NASA und der erste Schritt ist, quasi einzuspuren.
Wir gehen Richtung Uranus, sagen wir mal.
Und jetzt gibt es im Wesentlichen, bis dass diese Mission auf dem Launchpad sitzt.
Wirklich bereit ist zu gehen. Wie du gesagt hast, die schnellsten Missionen sind drei, vier Jahre.
Die ganz grossen Missionen sind 23 Jahre.
Übrigens, viele Fehler, das
ist nicht der Standard. Man sollte nie eine Mission für 23 Jahre machen.
Aber die Tatsache ist, es gibt so Abschnitte, quasi das erste Konzept,
was ist die Wissenschaft, die wir tun, bis zum Schluss, nach drei Jahren oder so, eine Confirmation.
Das heisst, wir haben das ganze System, wir verstehen es, wir wissen, was wir bauen müssen.
Jeder Teil weiss, was gebaut werden muss, wie teuer wird das sein.
Wir sagen, wie teuer. Dann sagen wir, wenn wir mehr als 15% drüber sind,
oder 5%, je nachdem, die grössere Zahl, muss ich zum Kongress und erklären, warum.
Die allermeisten Missionen, die wir bauen, sind innerhalb der Kosten.
Mit Covid usw. waren wir mehr drüber. Aber im Allgemeinen ist es normal,
dass wir alle bauen, so wie wir es sagen.
Jede in dieser Geschichte wird anfangs mehr wissenschaftskonzentriert.
Und dann wirklich auf das System und wirklich im Detail, was die Probleme sind.
Wie gesagt, der Chef der Wissenschaft der NASA löst nicht diese Probleme.
Wir haben riesige Probleme, wenn das bei Headquarters gelöst wird.
Das ist nicht das Problem. Aber was passiert, wenn eine Firma sich nicht darauf konzentriert?
Dann rufe ich an, den CEO.
Hey, besuch mich mal. Du hast einen Vertrag für 300 Millionen Dollar.
Es geht nicht gut. Ich wähle Veränderungen. Das ist mein Job,
einfach am Schluss zu helfen, wenn sonst alles nicht hilft. Ja.
Alle sozusagen auf Trab zu halten.
Genau, genau.
Also wenn dieser Auswahlprozess stattfindet, ich finde das ist interessant,
das ist auch immer glaube ich immer wichtig nochmal drüber nachzudenken,
dass es ja um die großen Fragen geht,
es geht wirklich sozusagen, man muss, man macht das ja nicht alles zum Spaß,
so ja wäre ja mal schön, wenn wir die Raketentechnik ausprobieren würden oder
so, sondern die ganze Technik wird ja immer gebaut, um einen bestimmten Zweck zu erfüllen.
Und der ist ja ultimativ die Beantwortung der offenen Fragen und die sind halt
dann sehr weitreichend.
Wenn man so eine Mission zusammenstellt, dann heißt das ja, es müssen viele
Prototypen gebaut werden, es muss ja viel Technik gebaut werden.
Wie und wer entscheidet, wie viele Kooperationen man macht und wie viel macht dann die NASA selbst?
Am Anfang war ja die NASA der Ort wo alles passiert ist. Man hat die Raketen
erst mal entwickelt. Es muss ja alles erst mal neu erfunden werden.
Gerade das Mondlandeprogramm war ja super extensiv.
Was da alles, wurde ja alles erfunden und alles war sagen wir mal unter staatlicher
Hoheit, alles war sozusagen die USA machen das jetzt.
Heute haben wir eine sehr viel diversere Landschaft.
Einerseits weil es Raumfahrtsorganisationen nicht nur in den USA gibt.
Jetzt kommt auch noch diese Privatisierung mit rein.
Zu welchem Zeitpunkt und wie geht man da strategisch ran, dass man sagt,
hier brauchen wir die JAXA, hier brauchen wir die ESA, wer auch immer.
Wie wird das ausgedealt?
Also auf der strategischen Seite. Die internationalen Partnerschaften,
die werden Headquarters, also die entscheide ich in meinem Job.
Und mein Team. Und wir haben ganz bewusste Ziele auch mit dem.
Die Tatsache ist für uns, insbesondere in der Präsenz von Leuten,
die andere Werte haben im Raum, als wir haben.
Wir brauchen bei NASA nicht nur, dass wir sagen, ich weiss, was wir tun, alles, was wir tun.
Wir sind konsistent mit den Regeln, denen wir sagen müssen. Wir folgen,
also in Zivil Luftwaffe brauchen wir nicht alles für das Militär.
Wir haben andere Agenturen für das in Amerika.
NASA braucht es, ist zivil. In dem Fall wollen wir, dass die Länder so viel
wie möglich zusammenarbeiten.
Wir haben das Gefühl, das hilft dem Frieden auf der Erde, es hilft auch,
uns grössere Ziele zu erreichen.
Ich bin wirklich ein – ob es im Raum ist mit dem Team, aber auch,
ob es internationale Partnerschaften sind – Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, dass diverse ...
Meinungen und andere Approaches, etwas zu tun, dass die uns helfen,
besser zu sein. Wir können mehr tun, besser tun, wenn wir zusammenarbeiten.
Deshalb sind über zwei Drittel der Missionen bei NASA, wissenschaftliche Missionen,
haben internationale Teile für unsere Human Exploration.
Also mit Astronautinnen und Astronauten haben wir alle grosse Systeme,
haben internationale Teile, insbesondere von Europa.
Orion in Deutschland, ganz klar, die gebaut, also Teile davon.
Thema meiner letzten Sendung, das Service-Modul wird von der ESA gebaut.
Genau. Es ist wirklich spektakulär, diese Maschine. Und dann natürlich JAXA,
also von Japan, aber auch andere, die Emirate und dann auch einzelne Länder
von Europa, Kanada und so weiter.
Also wir bauen das ganz bewusst.
Auf der kommerziellen Seite, die Partnerschaften, ist das, glaube ich,
eine der Dinge, auf die NASA unglaublich stolz sein soll.
Aber es ist unglaublich schwierig, das immer noch zu tun. Die Tatsache ist,
die Regel, die ich immer gebraucht habe, und das ist eigentlich die Regel dort,
wenn man etwas kaufen kann, bauen wir es nicht selber.
Das ist absolut klar und das wollen wir so.
Das heisst, für die allermeisten Missionen bauen wir keine Satelliten mehr.
Wir bauen keine Raketen mehr. Wir bauen.
Asterix, eine Rakete haben wir noch gebaut, SLS. Jetzt für die neue Industrie.
Space Launch System für Artemis I zum Beispiel.
Wir können später darüber sprechen, wie das weitergeht. Aber die Tatsache ist,
es ist ein riesiger Erfolg für NASA,
für Amerika, NASA zusammen mit der Air Force über die Space Force,
dass zum Beispiel wir Firmen haben, zwei bis drei Firmen in jedem Segment,
das Launch, die wir haben.
Und wir bauen die nicht mehr innerhalb der Regierung. Wir sind Kunden von diesen Firmen.
Das ist eine Entwicklung, die eine Rolle spielt. Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass es in der Zukunft viel weitergeht.
Zum Beispiel eine der Programme, die ich in den letzten sechs Jahren gebaut
habe, ist, dass wir nicht nur Satelliten bauen, die die Erde beobachten,
sondern Daten kaufen von Firmen, die schon Satelliten haben,
die die Erde beobachten.
Wir kaufen diese Daten quasi als Zweitimarkt und stellen sie zur Verfügung zur Wissenschaft.
Das heisst, dass plötzlich neue Datenquellen zur Verfügung stehen,
die wir keinen Dollar auf die Satelliten ausgegeben haben. Ehrlich gesagt,
die können das viel billiger tun, als wir das könnten.
Und das ist richtig so. Diese kommerziellen Partnerschaften sind wirklich ein
riesiger Teil der Führungsstrategie der USA.
Ja und das ist ja auch so der Trend. Ich meine am Anfang musste man halt alles
selber machen, weil es gab ja noch nichts und letzten Endes ist ja die Raumfahrt
in den USA, wie in Europa, wie auch überall sonst ja eigentlich auch so ein
Motor der wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung.
Durch diese komplexen Projekte ist es erforderlich, immer wieder Prototypen zu bauen,
neue Materialien, Methoden zu erfinden,
ob Solarpaneele sind oder spezielle Keramiken, Hitzebeständigkeit,
all diese ganzen Anforderungen finden ja dann letzten Endes auch den Weg in
die normale Wirtschaft und lassen das Wirtschaftsleben dann eben auch entsprechend aufleben.
Einerseits und auf der anderen Seite ist es sozusagen dieses Selbstverständnis,
auch ein Motor der Wissenschaft selber zu sein und dass das ja eigentlich das primäre Ziel ist,
diese Wissensgewinnung sozusagen wirklich auch als finale Dienstleistung an
die Gesellschaft etwas zu liefern, was im Prinzip sagt, wir liefern euch Erkenntnisse, oder? Genau.
Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, dass eben als Wissenschaftschef der NASA – und ich glaube,
dass das auch der Fall ist mit Wissenschaftschef in Deutschland,
in verschiedenen Organisationen, nicht nur im Raum – als Wissenschaftler,
insbesondere in der Grundlagenforschung, die wir bei der NASA tun,
ich würde immer so sagen, ist eine der wichtigsten Teile der Menschheit.
Wirklich sich Gedanken zu machen über uns selber, über uns, unsere Geschichte, mit dem grossen G.
Also Geschichte nicht nur von Geburt zu uns, sondern der Menschheit,
des Planetens, des Universums, in dem wir drin sind.
Das ist unsere Geschichte, wenn wir das Universum sehen. Sondern auch zu verstehen,
was wirklich die Regeln im Universum sind, die das Ganze zusammenhalten.
Ob das unsere eigene Erde ist, mit den verschiedenen Teilen dieses komplexen
Systems, dieses wunderschönen Planeten, das unser Heim ist.
Oder ob das ist, um zu verstehen, wie ein Bose-Einstein-Kondensat in Schwerelosigkeit funktioniert.
Wirklich Materie in einem ganz ungewöhnlichen Status. Etwas,
woran Deutschland sehr viel arbeitet und wirklich führend ist. zusammen mit Amerika.
Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, dass.
Wissenschaft, und insbesondere intellektuell aggressive Wissenschaft,
ein grosser Treiber für die Menschheit ist, weil sie Lösungen zur Verfügung
stellt für die Zukunft, für die Probleme der Zukunft. Heute.
Als ich aufgestanden bin, oder vom Flugzeug weggegangen bin,
was auch immer heute passiert ist, habe ich die Wettervoraussagen benutzt.
Als wir angefangen hatten mit Satelliten, das erste schwarz-weiss Foto der Erde,
man sieht die Ozeane, die Wolken, aber sonst nicht viel.
Da hätte niemand gedacht, dass die Wettervoraussagen so gut sein werden und
dass 80% der wirklichen Informationen vom Raum kommen wird. Das ist heute so weltweit.
Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, das ist ein unglaublicher Dienst der Menschheit.
Insbesondere vom Wetter, das auch Leben zerstören kann.
Grosse Stürme, Feuer und so weiter. Und das ist eine interessante Erde zu beobachten.
Also fundamentale Wissenschaft der Erde ist immer noch wichtig.
Interessant, aber diese Einsichten helfen uns auch, Sorge zu tragen zur Erde,
aber auch Leben zu retten auf der Erde.
Es gibt Hunderte und Tausende Beispiele von dem. GPS ist ein anderes.
Die Technologie kam natürlich nicht aus der Wissenschaft heraus,
aber die Anwendung kam aus dem Militär.
Heute ein riesen Markt in GPs, also ausserhalb des Militärs.
Viele der Anwendungen, Kommunikation, viele der Dinge, die heute uns selbstverständlich
sind, kamen aus der Wissenschaft.
Und die grossen Ideen, die grossen Innovationsideen, kommen alle aus der fundamentalen Wissenschaft.
Ich sage mal, ohne Raumfahrt kein Handy. Also das Produkt wäre vollständig unmöglich
ohne Raumfahrt gewesen.
Sieht denn das die Gesellschaft genauso und wie sieht es speziell auch nochmal
so die amerikanische Gesellschaft?
Wie ist die Wahrnehmung der NASA in den USA?
So aus deiner Perspektive und vielleicht kannst du das auch mal mit Europa vergleichen.
Ich habe oft den Eindruck, dass vielen diese umfangreichen Beiträge für Wissenschaft
und Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft so nicht so bewusst sind.
Es ist absolut so, dass der Wert der Wissenschaft, nicht nur der Wert der Raumforschung,
sondern allgemein der Wert der Wissenschaft sehr unterschiedlich von verschiedenen
Menschen aufgenommen wird.
Insbesondere in der Raumforschung muss ich sagen, dass in den letzten 15 Jahren
Raumforschung sehr trendy geworden ist.
Man kann eigentlich fast nirgendwo hinwandern, ohne dass man jemanden sieht mit einem NASA-Shirt.
Ich habe eines an heute.
Und ich meine, Teenager, alle, die haben das.
Ein Modeartikel ist cool, das zu tun. Die private Raumforschung,
SpaceX, all diese Firmen, die haben damit geholfen.
Wir wissen auch, dass NASA einen grossen Trust Factor hat.
Das Vertrauen der allgemeinen Bevölkerung in Amerika ist sehr hoch in der NASA.
Im Vergleich zu anderen wissenschaftlichen Organisationen, Auch der Kongress,
der Präsident usw. NASA ist viel, viel höher.
Aber es ist wirklich so, dass das Bewusstsein des Wertes unterschiedlich aufgenommen wird.
Und auch von ganz Anfang an, was viele Menschen vergessen,
ist, dass die meiste Zeit während
des Apollo-Programms, Das war einer der grössten Erfolge von Amerika.
Die Unterstützung in der Bevölkerung war weniger als 50 Prozent.
Erst ganz am Schluss ging es hoch. Tatsächlich? Absolut. Die Unterstützung von
Menschen ist nicht die beste Voraussage für Erfolg.
Ich sage immer, als Führer muss man wissen, was wichtig ist.
Das verstehen, ohne dass alle klatschen.
Das ist das Ziel der Führung, dass man etwas tut, obwohl die Leute noch nicht
verstehen, warum es wichtig ist.
Man muss mutig sein.
Absolut. Mut gehört dazu.
Die Menschen, die Mut haben, auch etwas zu tun, nicht nur darüber zu sprechen,
etwas zu tun, sind die, die wirklich die Zukunft ändern und insbesondere verbessern.
Es hat ja in den USA enorm zu so einem kulturellen Stolz auch auf die NASA geführt.
Also ich denke das ist schon auch etwas aus der Ferne, zumindest so Wahrnehmer,
dass NASA ist halt eigentlich mehr so ein Kulturgut schon der Gesellschaft geworden,
das ist irgendwie da, das steht für etwas.
Es hat auch eine unfassbare internationale Abstrahlkraft, es wird nahezu überall
auch sehr positiv wahrgenommen.
Mit der ESA zum Beispiel ist es etwas schwieriger in der europäischen Wahrnehmung.
Wie siehst du die Rolle der ESA und was da hier noch nicht so geklickt hat?
Ehrlich muss ich sagen, obwohl ich einen Schweizer Akzent habe,
habe ich meine ganze Karriere nach meinem Doktorat in Amerika verbracht.
Ich verstehe Europa viel weniger gut, als man denken würde, wenn man mir zuhört.
Aber was bei NASA hilft und was uns wirklich hilft ...
Wir haben bei NASA ein Apparat aufgebaut, der aufgrund der Kommunikation wirklich
besser ist als viele in Amerika, aber auch international.
Wir sind viel, viel transparenter zum Beispiel.
Mit James Webb wussten die Bevölkerung, die Journalisten, alle Probleme. Ganz bewusst.
Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, ich bin nicht inspiriert von Superheroes,
die Menschen oder Helden, die auf Wasser gehen, die fliegen können. Ich bin nicht so.
Ich bin ein Mensch, der hat Stärken und Schwächen, mache manchmal falsche Entscheidungen,
manchmal habe ich unglaublich Mühe.
Aber wenn Menschen zusammenkommen, können sie diese unglaublichen Teams bauen,
die viel besser sind als jeder einzelne Mensch.
Und wenn man das sieht, ob es auf dem Sportplatz ist, ein Team,
das zusammenkommt und wirklich etwas tut.
Und wenn man es sieht, bei der NASA ganz transparent, also wirklich die Kamera
läuft immer, wenn wir landen auf dem Mars.
Wir hatten keine Ahnung, ob es funktioniert.
Ich habe die Rede in meiner Tasche, die ich nicht geben will.
Manchmal übe ich sie sogar. Aber die Tatsache ist, wir wollen die Menschen dazu inspirieren.
Wir haben das wirklich bewusst gemacht.
Was manchmal schwierig ist, ist, dass NASA hilft. Es gibt eine Quelle von Geld,
und das ist das amerikanische Budget.
Das hat natürlich auch negative Dinge, weil die amerikanische Politik ist die
amerikanische Politik.
Aber in ESA, was schwierig ist, ist diese mehrere Länder, die Stärke von ESA,
die unglaubliche Stärke. Darum ist ESA so unglaublich gut.
Aber wenn es dann manchmal zur Kommunikation geht, gibt diese Vielfalt manchmal
ein wenig Reibung, habe ich gesehen.
Und ich glaube, wenn ich mehr in Europa arbeiten würde, würde ich mehr an dem arbeiten.
Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, es hilft allen, wirklich die beste Geschichte
zu erzählen. Und dann am Schluss aufzuholen.
In der Natur ist es unglaublich wichtig festzustellen, welche Grösse erhalten
sind und welche nicht erhalten sind. Zum Beispiel Masse ist erhalten.
Man kann ein Kilogramm Masse, man kann tun, was man will. Am Schluss ist immer
noch ein Kilogramm Masse.
Wie auch immer ist erhalten. Credit, also wer die Leute sagen,
ist zuständig für den Erfolg, ist nicht eine erhaltene Grösse.
Alle können hundertprozentig sagen, was sie wollen. Und alle sollen gepriesen
werden. Man soll nicht ganz wenig die Elbogen raustun.
Denn das hilft der Geschichte eben nicht. Die Geschichte wird weniger gut.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Josef Aschbacher das wirklich versteht.
Also der Chef, der ist ein guter Freund übrigens, einer meiner.
Besten Freunde.
Ich war zu Gast bei Raumzeit im Übrigen.
Ja, er ist wirklich ein guter Mann, der versteht das wirklich genauso gut.
Ich glaube, man sieht schon jetzt, wie er dem wirklich hilft.
Aber ESA ist einfach komplizierter.
Ich finde es interessant, dass du gerade die Risiken schon mehrfach angesprochen
hast und dass es auch wichtig ist zu kommunizieren.
Ich glaube im Vergleich ESA, NASA, mir fehlt auch immer so ein bisschen eben
so dieser Mut eben auch eine Fehlerkultur wirklich voranzubringen und das dann
auch in der öffentlichen Kommunikation ist.
Vielleicht schon ein bisschen besser geworden, aber so die guten Beispiele habe
ich gerade auch in den letzten Jahren immer bei der NASA gesehen.
Inbegriff fand ich dieses großartige Video zur Mars-Landung mit diesen 7 Minutes of Terror.
Also was einfach wirklich so ein Filmchen war,
wer es nicht gesehen hat, wo also diese komplette Landephase,
diese komplexen einzelnen Schritte und was halt alles schief gehen kann,
Oben diese immer wieder doch sehr schwierige Landung von so einem riesigen Gerät
von der Größe eines Autos ja,
auf einem anderen Planeten, um das durchzuführen und dadurch,
dass man von Anfang an immer klar macht, hier ist das, was alles schief gehen
kann, wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert so, ja.
Und das macht dann irgendwie klar,
dass es schwierig ist, was man tut, dass es auch schiefgehen kann,
einfach weil es eben schwierig ist und dass es halt auch irgendwie okay ist,
weil man auch daraus lernen kann.
Dann gab es ja eine nicht so gelungene Marslandung der ESA Mission,
ja wo also dieser Schiaparelli aufgeschlagen ist auf dem Boden aus,
weiß nicht mal ganz genau, mal herausgefunden, was die Gründe waren,
ist eigentlich auch egal und es war dann so schwierig,
weil die ganze Kommunikation irgendwie immer nur auf Erfolg gebürstet war und
in dem Moment, wo sich dieser Erfolg nicht einstellt, dann wird's auf einmal
schwierig das zu kommunizieren.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch so eine gewisse Verspanntheit, die vielleicht so
ein bisschen den Europäern an der Stelle auch eigen ist,
während diese manchmal so auch ein bisschen nervige Lockerheit der Amerikaner
sehr hilft, an der Stelle so etwas zu kommunizieren.
Also Risikomanagement ist ja so ein bisschen auch so der Kern eigentlich der Tätigkeit, oder?
Absolut. Ich glaube, alles, was du gerade gesagt hast, ist wirklich richtig.
Kultur, wie man mit Risiken umgeht, ist wirklich eine kulturelle Art und Weise.
Wir sprechen nur über ESA und NASA jetzt, aber wir könnten auch Japan dazu tun.
Ganz eine andere Art und Weise darüber zu sprechen. Ich meine,
die Japaner, ich habe sehr viel, auch manchmal ohne Kameras,
viele Diskussionen mit.
Japan, auch Indien zum Beispiel. Wie spricht man darüber, dass man Schwierigkeiten
hat? Wie spricht man darüber?
Niemand darf das wissen, sonst verliere ich meinen Stand. Statusprobleme. Ja, genau.
Und ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, dass eine der Stärken, wie gesagt,
jede Stärke ist auch eine Schwäche. Je nach Situation.
Ich glaube nicht daran, dass eine Art und Weise besser ist als die andere.
Jede Stärke hat auch Schwächen.
Amerika hat auch Schwächen, die Europa nicht hat.
Aber die Stärke in dem Fall, mit Risiko so umzugehen, indem man darüber spricht,
ist etwas, was NASA gelernt hat, was aber in Amerika einfacher ist für uns.
Ist für uns mehr eine vergebene Kultur.
Insbesondere in der Kultur von Start-ups und in der Wirtschaft haben wir Menschen,
die Firmen nicht erfolgreich waren.
Und die können wieder probieren. Es ist nicht so, dass das ganze Leben vorbei
ist, wenn sie mal eine Firma in den Konkurs geführt haben.
Ich glaube, das ist wirklich eine Stärke, die eine neue Unternehmerskultur baut.
Und es ist etwas, was man auch lernen kann.
Also wirklich, dass man darüber spricht. Insbesondere die Führer dieser Firmen
können darüber sprechen.
Ich kenne mich gut mit der Web. Ich hatte ein Problem mit dem James Webb Space
Telescope, das war eine Anekdote, um darüber zu sprechen.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass die Mission mit dem grössten Risiko,
das ich geleitet habe, risikohaft war.
Wir hatten unglaubliche Schwierigkeiten. Ich kam am Anfang der Mission rein
und merkte, dass sie wirklich Probleme hatte.
Ich habe die Mission fast verloren. Ich habe es gefunden, habe sofort gepflückt,
habe viele Führer entlassen usw.
Aber das Team war so gebaut mit alten Werten.
Die wollten nie darüber sprechen, dass sie Schwierigkeiten haben.
Und ich habe ganz bewusst, als wir gegen Ende der Mission waren,
das Team wurde immer besser, immer besser, immer besser. Und ganz am Schluss war es unglaublich.
Besser, als sie dachten, sie seien. Ich habe niemanden gefunden im ganzen Team,
der vorausgesagt hat, wie gut das gehen wird. Also so gut waren wir.
Also nicht nur der Ablauf des Starts und des Deployments, sondern auch die Wissenschaft,
die am Ende dabei rauskommt.
Mega, alle Funktionen funktionieren besser als gedacht.
Genau, viel besser als wir gedacht haben. Aber was ich gemacht habe,
ganz am Schluss, das hat mir wirklich Sorgen gemacht.
Weil wir nie über Risiken gesprochen haben, weniger als an anderen Missionen.
Und das Problem, das ich hatte, ist, wenn wir nicht über Risiken sprechen,
ganz bewusst, Und wenn wir ein Problem haben, kommt der ganze politische Apparat.
Der politische Apparat auf mich los. Und ehrlich gesagt, die Leute können nicht unabhängig arbeiten.
Ich wollte das Team beschützen, indem ich von Anfang an quasi sagte,
das ist unglaublich schwierig. Ich habe einen Blog geschrieben, ganz bewusst.
Der Kernsatz dieses Blogs war, wenn du nicht Angst hast oder sogar wenn du Angstträume
hast über diese Mission, dann verstehst du nicht, was wir tun.
Wenn du keine Angst hast, verstehst du nicht, was wir tun wollen hier.
Und dann wurde das Team, insbesondere die Chefs, sehr nervös.
Glaubst du nicht, dass wir das tun können? Absolut glaube ich es.
Least den nächsten Satz. Der nächste Satz ist, wir haben das beste Team,
um das zu tun im Moment. Ich glaube, wir werden erfolgreich sein,
aber ich bin sicher, es wird schwierig sein.
Das war wirklich die beste Idee, das zu tun.
Wirklich ganz bewusst darüber sprechen und wir haben die ganze Pair,
von Anfang an, dieser Plan wurde gemacht,
wir hatten nur drei Presse-Communicators, also nach dem Launch,
nur drei bis alles fertig war, bis in den Juli, also vom Dezember bis in den Juli.
Wir haben das geändert auf jede Woche im Deployment und dann alle zwei Wochen beim Kalibrieren.
Und das hat die ganze Medienwelt mitgefiebert.
Ich gehe noch jetzt, wenn ich in ein Hotel reingehe, auf einem Flugzeug,
die Menschen sprechen über James Webb, weil sie verstehen, dass es schwierig war.
Und ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, das muss nicht amerikanisch sein.
Das kann auch in Europa gemacht werden. Es braucht ein wenig Mut.
Ich habe auch mitgefiebert. Ich auch. Absolut.
Ich hab mit Hans Königsmann von SpaceX, hab ich hier auch schon gesprochen über so,
wie die halt auch mit dem Risiko und der Fehlerkultur umgegangen sind,
da findet sich jetzt viel wieder von dem was du gesagt hast,
so ein bisschen so eben dieses Mut zum Scheitern ist einfach glaube ich sehr
wichtig, wenn man die wirklich großen Dinge erreichen will und dann auch eben
ein Scheitern dann auch selbst überlebt.
Und da ist glaube ich gerade Europa so ein bisschen in so einer Schockstarre
und obwohl die Technologie super ist, denke ich, muss ich hier Europa mal wieder
ein bisschen auf den Weg begeben.
Ich würde jetzt ganz gerne nochmal so zurück zu den Missionen.
Jetzt hatten wir ja schon ganz am Anfang, wie kommt man überhaupt erstmal auf
die Aufgabenstellung, dann kommen eben frische Missionen, wir haben jetzt schon
gehört, Missionen, die halt sozusagen auch Betreuung brauchen.
Mir fällt eine andere Mission an, die ja auch in deine Zeit gefallen ist, Mars 2020.
Also die Landung des zweiten großen Rover, des Perseverance Rovers und auch
noch mit meinem besonderen Liebling, dem Ingenuity, diesem kleinen Helikopter,
der noch hinterher fliegt.
Dieser Helikopter war ja für mich so ein bisschen der Inbegriff des Vagemoods,
dass man also wirklich eine ohnehin schon super komplexe Mission,
die so ganz klare Ziele hat, dann aber auch nochmal mit etwas bestückt,
wo man sagt, das probieren wir jetzt nochmal aus, wer weiß, vielleicht funktioniert
es ja sogar, weil ich glaube die Erwartungen waren gar nicht so hoch, oder?
Also, als ich zur NASA kam, haben mir alle Chefs gesagt, der Helikopter macht keinen Sinn. Kill den.
Ehrlich gesagt, die verstehen nicht, wie ich denke. Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass Führung immer zu tun hat, zu wagen.
Immer. Ich habe ein Motto gebaut in meiner Zeit bei der NASA.
Jede Mission muss etwas Neues dran haben, sonst will ich nichts damit zu tun haben.
Wir müssen besser werden. Ich habe wirklich viel von SpaceX gestohlen.
Man macht eben die Raketen besser, man baut nicht immer die Gleiche,
man baut sie immer besser.
Der Helikopter war so. Ich habe das erste Meeting mit denen gemacht.
Sie kamen zu mir und gaben einen Vortrag, den man eben nicht geben soll.
Ich sagte, alles sei gut, wir wissen, wie man das tut. Ich fragte,
wie sie das Risiko einschätzen. Sie sagten, es sei ein Low-Risk.
Habe ich gesagt, okay, du bist vom Rover weg.
Wenn du nicht weisst, dass das ein hohes Risiko hat, hast du keine Chance, das zu tun.
Du musst dir den Weg wieder verdienen, auf den Rover zurück.
Ich habe zwei, drei Dinge gemacht, von mir aus, um denen zu helfen.
Das erste ist, ich habe gesagt, dass der Mechanismus, das den Helikopter auf
den Mars aufsetzt, darf nicht vom JPL selbst gebaut werden.
Sie müssen zu jemand anderem. Was ich tun wollte, und ehrlich gesagt,
im Nachhinein war es wichtiger, ich habe nicht so tief darüber nachgedacht.
Es war eine wirklich gute Idee, aber ich habe es aus einem leicht anderen Grund
gemacht. Aber es war eine gute Idee.
Die hatten nicht genug Kapazität, das zu tun, darum habe ich es gemacht.
Aber es war eine wirklich gute Idee, weil es quasi.
Den Helikopterabschnitt vom Rover. Also mit anderen Worten, die mussten sagen,
hey, so wird der an den Rover gehen, fertig. Du baust das jetzt,
wir können das nicht mehr ändern. Also mit anderen Worten...
Also Ingenuity ist ja unter dem Rover abgesetzt worden und dann ist er weggefahren.
Weil das Schlimmste, das passieren kann, ist, dass der Helikopter rauskommt
und dann am Rover hängen bleibt.
Und dann können wir die Mission nicht tun, für die wir zweieinhalb Milliarden
ausgegeben haben. Das darf nicht passieren.
Mit anderen Worten, der Helikopter muss ein System sein, der nicht den Rover
beeinflusst. Der hängt wirklich unten dran. Das ist die erste gute Idee.
Die zweite gute Idee ist, ich habe ihnen gesagt, es darf nicht mehr kosten als
eine Zahl. Ich habe ihnen das Maximum, 80 Millionen, glaube ich.
Ich habe ihnen gesagt, es darf nicht mehr kosten. Der Grund,
warum ich das gemacht habe, ist nicht wegen dem Geld, sondern weil ich sie von
der Bürokratie beschützen wollte.
Das ist ein interessantes Projekt, das alle helfen wollen. Das heisst,
dass am Schluss 100 Leute die Arbeit von 10 tun.
Und das gibt viel, viel mehr.
Wenn man wirklich etwas so Schwieriges macht, muss man es mit einem kleinen
Team tun, das 150 Prozent ihres Herzens und Ihres Hirns da reinsteckt.
Als sie das gemacht haben, habe ich sie zurück auf den Rover gebracht.
Ehrlich gesagt, habe ich meine Zeit damit verbracht. Die Leute sind unglaublich
gut, die zuständig waren.
Aber von der Führungsseite habe ich sie von der Bürokratie beschützt.
Ich habe gesagt, du musst nicht dasselbe tun wie der Rover. Als der Helikopter
flieg oder fliegen wollte, ging es nicht zum ersten Mal. Ich war dort.
Der Grund, warum ich dort war, war nicht, um zu klatschen.
Ich wollte das Team auch dort beschützen von der Fehlerkultur von NASA.
Ich wollte nicht, dass 100 Menschen denen helfen.
Als es nicht ging, ging ich sofort auf die Kamera mit der Chefin,
Mimi Ang, unglaubliche Geschichte, Immigrantin, also ein Flüchtling,
Myanmarer, ein Immigrant, eine unglaubliche Frau.
Und ich sagte ihm vor die Kamera, dass er schon alle Rekorde gebrochen hat.
Er war noch nie ein fliegendes Gefährte auf dem Mars. Er wird das sicher herausfinden,
aber wenn nicht, hat er schon alle Rekorde gebrochen.
Und auf alle gesagt, back off!
Wir gehen nicht in diesen Modus, in dem wir denen helfen.
Und dann kam der erste Flug. Der erste Flug ging und wir wollten vier Flüge
machen und vor kurzem hatten wir den 44.
Flug abgeschlossen. 44. schon? Oh Gott, ich hab's gar nicht verstanden.
Und in der Zwischenzeit brauchen wir Helikopter für Mars Sample Return,
also um diese Proben zurückzukriegen.
Wir haben diese Helikopter gebaut als kleine Versicherung, wenn etwas falsch geht mit dem Rover.
Ja und es ist ja vor allem etwas entstanden, was so überhaupt nicht geplant
war. Eigentlich war so der Rover, das war so die Mission, der fährt da so rum,
der macht da so sein Ding, kennen wir schon, haben wir ja schon mal so ähnlich schon mal gemacht.
Und durch dieses kleine Projekt, was jetzt sehr viel länger gehalten hat,
ich weiß nicht, was hat man gedacht, wie viele Flüge, was hast du gesagt?
Vier, vier Booten länger.
Vier Flüge sollten, so jetzt ist es halt schon irgendwie das Elffache davon
und auf einmal wird es eine ganz andere Mission,
weil der Helikopter fliegt voraus, schaut schon mal,
wo könnten wir denn mal was interessantes finden, ja, also auch überhaupt diese Vorstellung,
dass da sozusagen so zwei Roboter sich gegenseitig helfen und jedes Ding auch
so seine eigenen Fähigkeiten sozusagen mit reinbringt und man ja vielleicht
dann auch, ja, so weiterdenken kann.
Bei diesen Planetenexplorationen, dass man sagt, ja okay, wir haben jetzt das
mit dem Fahrzeug, das haben wir fliegen können, vielleicht fallen uns noch ein
paar andere Sachen ein und wir können das dann irgendwie ganz gut kombinieren.
Es gibt ja, ich weiß gerade nicht, wie die Mission heisst, aber es wird ja eine neue Mission.
Dragonfly.
Dragonfly für den Titan, genau.
Da hab ich auch gestartet, ja.
Das geht ja im Prinzip in die gleiche Richtung.
Genau. Wenn man diesen Luftraum für Drohnen dazu bringt, gibt es total neue Optionen.
Und für mich, wenn man etwas Neues… Man vergisst immer die Geschichte.
Zum ersten Mal als wir einen Rover auf den ...
Mars gestaltet haben. Die ganze wissenschaftliche Community fragte,
warum vergeudest du unsere Zeit mit Reden.
Wir können alles tun, was wir wollen auf dem Mars mit Ländern,
also wie Viking und so die ersten wieder.
In der Zwischenzeit will jeder Wissenschaftler einen Rover, weil man so die
ganze Gegend erforschen kann, eben viel mehr als mit einem einzigen Ländern.
Das Problem war, dass wir das technisch und finanziell gelöst hatten.
Das Problem waren die Antibodies der wissenschaftlichen Community.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich erinnere mich, am Schluss,
vor dem Start, habe ich dem Chefwissenschaftler der Mission angerufen und gesagt,
Du wirst in der nächsten Pressekonferenz positiv über den Helikopter sprechen.
Aber ich bin nicht dafür. Du wirst darüber positiv sprechen,
sonst finde ich einen anderen Chef.
Du musst nicht sagen, es sei wichtig für die Wissenschaft, aber du kannst sagen,
es sei wichtig für Technologien und für den Fortschritt. Und du wirst das sagen.
Er war sehr zornig über mich. Er hat es natürlich gemacht, weil er seinen Job wollte.
Aber die Tatsache ist, am Schluss war er der Mann, der den Helikopter gerettet
hat. Nach vier Flügen sagte ich, der Helikopter muss sich selber beweisen.
Hat er gesagt, hey, wir können da drüben, gibt's so ein Dünenfeld.
Wir können dort nicht hinfahren, weil der Rover bleibt stecken.
Können wir dort hinfliegen und Bilder machen?
Okay, ja, können wir. Gehen wir.
Ah, okay, wir haben zwei Wege, mehr nach links oder mehr nach rechts.
Kannst du vorausfliegen und sehen, welcher der einfachere Weg ist? Ja, können wir.
Und darum, wirklich dieses Werkzeug zu brauchen, um die Wissenschaft zu unterstützen.
Manchmal muss man ein wenig Medizin geben, bis so ein Werkzeug da ist.
Ich bin unglaublich stolz auf dieses Team, aber auch auf die Idee.
Übrigens, diese Tech-Demo, die anzuhängen auf anderen Missionen ...
Es gibt eine Mission, die wir bauen, die heisst Nancy Grace Roman.
Es ist wie der Hubble Space Telescope, aber 200-mal grösser als Field of View.
Es ist viel schneller. Wir können den ganzen Himmel ablichten in Infrarot mit Hubble-Auflösung.
Dort gibt es eine Tech-Demo, die daran hängt, die heisst Coronagraph.
Das ist nicht nötig für die Mission.
Ich bin unglaublich froh, dass wir die angehängt haben. Wie gesagt,
wir haben auch gesagt, wie viel sie kosten dürfen.
Und haben das entwickelt.
Diese Tech-Demo wird, glaube ich, die wichtigste Schritt sein für die nächste grosse Mission.
Das Habit of the World Observatory, das Observatorium, um wirklich andere Erden
in unserer Galaxie zu finden. Das nächste grosse Teleskop.
Diese Tech-Demo wird der wichtigste Schritt sein. Und wir haben das gemacht,
bevor wir wussten, dass das die nächste Strategie ist.
Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, dass es wichtig ist, auch Geld auszugeben auf
brilliante neue Technologien, um die wirklich zu entwickeln,
dass wir sie zur Verfügung haben.
Diese Mission ist vielleicht jetzt auch nochmal ein ganz gutes Beispiel schon,
wäre so fast meine nächste Frage gewesen, jetzt ist so eine Mission in Fullswing,
also ich meine so diese ganze Vorplanung und dann irgendwie erst bis zum Launch
bringen und sozusagen den größten Teil geschafft zu haben,
Aber so richtig spannend in gewisser Hinsicht wird es ja dann erst,
wenn das Ding so richtig in Wallung kommt.
Man hat es jetzt hier gesehen durch diese ganze Flexibilität, die dort gezeigt wird.
Bei James Webb ist es ja schon ähnlich, weil dann auf einmal Dinge passieren,
dann kommen irgendwelche Kometen angeflogen und müssen dann beobachtet werden
und auf einmal stellt man fest, Oh wow, jetzt haben wir irgendwie so fünf Instrumente,
die alle irgendwie gleichzeitig dasselbe Ereignis im All mitnehmen,
was ja dann auch nochmal einen ganz kompletten neuen Wert hat.
Wie dynamisch ist dann dieses Geschäft dann zu diesem Zeitpunkt und das ist
ja dann auch nochmal sozusagen jetzt aus der Direktoratsperspektive,
wie schnell kann der Apparat auf so etwas reagieren?
Eines der Werte, die wir bei NASA haben, ist, dass wir wirklich runterdelegieren,
wie wir den Satelliten brauchen. Mit anderen Worten, die kommen nicht zu mir.
Wir wollen die beste Wissenschaft tun. Und wir wollen die Ideen finden auf der
ganzen Welt, um die beste Wissenschaft zu tun.
Und wirklich dem Team die Flexibilität geben, um sich anzupassen auf diese neuen
Ideen und wirklich mit denen umzugehen.
Und wir machen das ganz bewusst so.
Es gibt ab und zu, Osiris Rex kommt zurück,
im September wird so eine Probe vom Asteroid Bennu,
dass wir in 2020 gesammelt haben, wird das abgeben in Utah.
Auf einem Fallschirm kommt das runter. Wir brauchen diesen Satelliten wieder.
Wir haben einen neuen, wir gehen zu Apophis, also einer dieser Asteroiden,
der sehr nah an der Erde vorbeifliegen wird. Wir gehen auf den los.
Ab und zu können wir eine Mission total neu definieren. Wir wollen wirklich
über die Strategie sprechen,
aber im Allgemeinen habe ich das Gefühl, um Wissenschaft zu maximalisieren,
ist für grosse Bürokraten Wegzustehen.
Wir wollen die Mission messen auf den Output. Wie wichtig sind sie?
Ich erwarte von James-Worx Festalskop-Nobelpreise.
Wenn es keine Nobelpreise gibt, weiss ich nicht, warum wir das tun.
Also ganz bewusst, also ich weiss, Nobelpreise sind sehr, ich weiss nicht,
ob man drauf… Also nicht für das Teleskop, sondern für die Wissenschaft,
die daraus entsteht. Genau.
Wir wollen wirklich die Natur mit einer neuen Art und Weise ansehen und wirklich verstehen,
in einer Art und Weise, die so neu ist, dass die höchste Stufe erreicht werden
kann, was auch die sein kann.
Und wir sollen das nicht von NASA aus entscheiden, was die richtige Wissenschaft
ist, Sondern eben die besten Ideen nehmen.
Wie ist denn das mit solchen Methusalem Projekten, die ja auch noch laufen?
Du hast es ja am Anfang schon erwähnt. Voyager 1.
Wie viele Leute kümmern sich eigentlich noch um diese Sonde?
Voyager 1 ist noch in Kontakt, Voyager 2 auch oder nicht mehr?
Beide, aber eines sieht weniger positiv aus als das andere. Wir haben ein Kommunikationsproblem
mit einem, aber wir haben es mit zwei, wir sind in Kontakt und es gibt Messungen.
Sehr auf Sparflamme jetzt. Wir haben wirklich das ganze Projekt runtergefahren.
Ehrlich gesagt, haben wir neue Wissenschaftler als Projekt getan.
Wir haben Programme gebaut, damit neue Ideen dort reinkommen.
Woyze würde ich mal sagen.
Wir verpassten ungefähr vor 15 Jahren, ich war dort nicht bei den NASA,
aber wir verpassten diese Mission total zu retoolen.
Wir hätten eine neue Generation von Wissenschaftlern auf dieses Projekt tun
müssen. Wir hätten mehr Wissenschaft herausbekommen, als wir haben.
Voyager ist eine so erfolgreiche Mission, dass das quasi eine kleine Störung
ist auf der grossen Erfolgsdimension dieser Mission.
Aber die Tatsache ist, was wirklich wichtig ist, und ich habe sehr damit gekümmert,
dass wir neue Wissenschaftler auf alte Missionen bringen.
Neue Energie, neue Ideen reinkriegen.
Also Voyager unter uns gesehen ist wahrscheinlich das schlechteste,
obwohl mit allen Erfolgen das schlechteste Beispiel, weil ich das Gefühl habe,
wir haben den Zeitpunkt verpackt und das machen wir nicht mehr.
Also wir haben ganz bewusst Missionen von neuen Führern übergeben.
Die Maven Mars Mission ist zum Beispiel eine meiner früher, Die wurden nicht
von mir entschieden, aber eine frühere Studentin von mir, die ist jetzt die Chefin dafür, Maven.
Das war ein anderer Mann, der mein Alter ist oder älter.
Wir wollen wirklich die neue Generation ausbilden und neue Ideen reinbringen.
Das ist absolut wichtig, ob es Voyager ist oder alle anderen.
Maven ist die Mars-Atmosphären-Mission.
Genau.
Ja, in dem Zusammenhang passt vielleicht auch die New Horizons Mission zum Pluto,
die ja auch außergewöhnlich erfolgreich war.
Super Start, eine der schnellsten Missionen,
also was die Fluggeschwindigkeit betrifft und dann diese wunderbaren Bilder
vom Pluto, wo ja immer noch dran ausgearbeitet wird, aber das Ding fliegt noch,
das Ding hat noch Kontakt und wir schießen dort sozusagen mit großer Geschwindigkeit ins All.
Es gab glaube ich zwei weitere Beobachtungen seit dem Pluto von Virgo.
AquaRot war ein Vorbeiflug, ein naher Vorbeiflug vor ungefähr fünf Jahren.
Das war ein unglaublicher Erfolg. Wirklich ein Kuiper-Belt-Objekt.
Es sieht so aus wie zwei Objekte zusammen. Es ist wirklich ein ganz altes,
ursprüngliches Objekt.
In den nächsten zwei Jahren werden auf New Horizons Wissenschaft gemacht,
nicht nur Beobachtungen vom Körperbild, die kleinen Körper,
die wir von dort aus beobachten können, sondern auch Beobachtungen,
die uns das Sodaic Light, also das Licht, das gestreut wird im inneren Sonnensystem,
Das ist quasi der Hintergrund zur ganzen Raumbeobachtung.
Wir werden Messungen machen, um das besser zu verstehen, weil wir auf der anderen
Seite davon sind, dass die Dichte dieses Staubs darunter kommt.
Wir machen diese Messungen. Und wir machen ganz bewusst Messungen über die Heliosphäre,
also die Plasmakomponente der Sonne und der Galaxie, in einem Energiebereich,
den wir noch nie gemacht haben.
Also das sind die grossen Prioritäten jetzt. Wir haben das vor gerade letztes
Jahr entschieden, was die nächste Stufe ist und was nach der passiert.
Sind denn dafür bei New Horizons Sensoren eingebaut worden, die jetzt für die
eigentliche Beobachtung des Pluto nicht herangezogen wurden?
Also gibt es noch irgendwelche zusätzlichen Instrumente, wo man gesagt hat,
können wir vielleicht noch gebrauchen, auch wenn es vielleicht jetzt beim Vorbeiflug
des Pluto keinen Sinn macht? Oder ist es einfach generell so,
dass die Instrumente, die man jetzt sowieso hat, genau für solche Sachen auch getaugt haben?
Es ist mehr das Zweite. Wir haben quasi Instrumente dort zum ersten Mal in der
Geschichte. Wir haben Kameras, die wirklich gut funktionieren, auch weit weg.
Die Voyager-Kameras waren zu kalt damals und hatten weniger Bitrate.
Wir konnten nicht die ganzen Bilder mit Farbkontrast runterbringen.
Wir können das mit New Horizons.
Der Plasma-Sensor war dort. Übrigens war das auf der Mission wegen des Plutons.
Der Pluton hat ja eine Atmosphäre, und die Atmosphäre wird geladen,
als diese neutralen Atmosphärenteile weggehen.
Wie auf der Erde werden sie geladen, und diese geladenen Teilchen können gemessen
werden mit einem solchen Sensor.
Darum war es auf der Mission.
Auch die Staubmessungen waren für den Pluton. Aber die Tatsache ist,
die werden wirklich neu erfunden.
Jetzt gibt es ja noch so ein anderes, großes, neues Ziel, was eigentlich ein
altes Ziel ist, nämlich der Mond.
Dieses schöne Timon Struppi-Comic-Reiseziel Mond.
Das scheint jetzt auch wieder ein neues Thema zu sein. Ist ja ganz klar.
Die Artemis-1-Mission legt ja hier schon kräftig vor.
Aber es gibt ja auch noch darüber hinaus große Ziele. Wie ist denn so die wissenschaftliche
Perspektive und wie hat sich die NASA dazu auch eingestellt,
was will man denn jetzt wieder machen mit dem Mond, worauf läuft's hin?
Spielt hier auch eine andere Nutzung des Mondes jenseits der Erforschung eine Rolle?
Auf jeden Fall. Erstens gesagt, über die Forschung.
Wir haben am Anfang über die nationale Strategie der Akademie gesprochen.
Wenn man diesen Plan sieht, merkt man, dass der Mond wirklich wichtige wissenschaftliche Ziele hat.
Ich würde sagen, wir gehen zum Mond zurück, aber wir gehen zurück zu einem Mond,
den wir noch nie gesehen haben. Weil sich das wissenschaftliche Bild des Mondes verändert hat.
Das sind zwei, drei Dinge, die wirklich anders sind. Erstens ist der Mond nicht
trocken, sondern ist nass. Mit anderen Worten, es gibt Wasser dort.
Wir haben das gemessen vom Orbit, aber wir waren noch nie auf der Oberfläche
und haben es dort gemessen und gesehen, ob wir das Wasser rauskriegen.
Übrigens, Wasser auf dem Mond, das war, was ich studiert habe in den 90ern, heresieren.
Absolut alle, jede Vorlesung wusste, es gibt dort nichts.
Und das ist wirklich interessant, wissenschaftlich gesehen. Das Zweite ist,
dass wir gemerkt haben, dass wirklich das Datum,
...
Der Erdgeschichte festzulegen, müssen wir auf den Mond. Und der Grund dafür
ist, dass sich die Erde zu sehr ändert.
Wegen der Geologie, der Erosion und so weiter.
Auf den Mond wissen wir, wo wir hin müssen, um wirklich das Datum der Erdgeschichte festzulegen.
In einer spezifischen Art und Weise. Und die dritte Priorität ist die,
die du schon angesprochen hast. Das ist die Tatsache, dass wir den Mond brauchen wollen.
Also ein Outpost, also wirklich eine Möglichkeit, ein Forschungsort,
von dem wir andere Missionen machen können. Die Frage ist, ob wir Wasser oder
andere Dinge vom Mond nehmen können, die uns helfen.
Wasser geht weniger ums Trinken, ehrlich gesagt. Wir wissen,
wie wir Wasser für Astronautinnen und Astronauten brauchen. Wir wissen,
wie wir das tun. Wir haben auf der Raumstation, wir haben Wasser,
wir können es wiederverwerten.
Wir haben die ganze Maschine. Also es ist nicht vor allem zum Trinken,
sondern um Treibstoff und Energie zu finden.
Also die Frage ist, können wir das nutzen? Gibt es andere Werte auf dem Mond?
Und wirklich, also die Frage, kommt der Mond in die Wirtschaftsphäre von Amerika
oder der westlichen Welt?
Also das ist die Frage, die auch mit dem Mond zu tun hat. Ja,
es ist fundamentale Wissenschaft, wirklich wichtige Wissenschaft.
Die Erdgeschichte, aber auch wirklich unerwartete Überraschungen vom Mond.
Das Zweite ist wirklich, ist das so ein Brückenkopf, Wirklich ein Ort,
von dem wir weitergehen können ins tiefere Sonnensystem.
Jetzt vielleicht mal zurück zur Erde.
Die Raumfahrt, die stellt ja auch die Erde vor ein paar Herausforderungen,
wenn man sich solche Projekte anschaut wie Starlink, Kuiper,
OneWeb, also die Erschließung von Dienstleistungen für Internet mit riesigen
Satellitenkonstellationen, solchen riesigen Netzwerken.
Es ist ja so, dass eine Disziplin vielleicht in den letzten Dekaden überhaupt
nicht mitgehalten hat mit der Entwicklung, nämlich die Weltraumpolitik.
Es ist eigentlich relativ wenig passiert und gerade jetzt sehen wir natürlich
eine ganze Menge Reibung mit Russland,
mit China auf der einen Seite, aber eben auch mit solchen privatwirtschaftlichen Dingen,
die Astronomen fluchen halt immer mehr,
Gerät, was ins All geht und die ganze Debatte darüber scheint nicht so richtig
stattzufinden und macht gerade auch einfach nicht so den Eindruck,
als ob sich irgendwie alle einig werden könnten und es gibt ja nun auch so ein
bisschen parallel, wie zum Klimawandel auf der Erde,
Wir haben sozusagen auch ein bisschen
Klimawandel im Orbit, weil Weltraumschrott ein großes Problem ist.
Es wird viel gestartet, aber in zunehmendem Maße treten Kollisionen auf und ähnliche Sachen.
Wie siehst du diese gesamte Situation? Ist sozusagen der Weltraumapparat,
der internationale, langfristig überhaupt noch in der Lage, sich so global zu
managen, dass das auch noch eine Zukunft hat?
Ja, also ehrlich gesagt mache ich mir Sorgen über genau dasselbe.
Nicht nur nachdem ich NASA verlassen habe, auch im Job bei der NASA.
Wenn wir unsere Raumforschung, quasi die Bedrohung uns ansehen.
Es gibt zwei Bedrohungen, die miteinander viel zu tun haben.
Das erste ist, dass der Raum eine Ebene wird vom Krieg.
Genauso wie Wasser. Wir haben ganze Armeen, die im Wasser, so Navy,
die gehen, ob es U-Boote sind oder was auch immer, quasi Wasser-Ozeane sind,
ein Ort, wo Krieg passieren kann.
Die Luft ist so ein Ort, wir haben Flugzeuge und so weiter, die Bomben werfen
können und wird der Raum auch so ein Ort des Krieges.
Und das Problem ist, wir wissen, dass GPS oder verschiedene Kommunikationssysteme,
die militärische Apparatur wird unterstützt vom Raum.
Aber die Frage ist, bringen wir Waffen in den Raum? Und die Regeln waren so,
dass wir gesagt haben, das tun wir nicht.
Die westliche Welt hat sich an diese Regeln gehalten, aber nicht die östliche, glauben wir.
Und das ist wirklich ein besorgniserregendes.
Das ist das erste Problem. Das zweite Problem ist dieser Weltraumschrott.
Nicht nur der Schrott, sondern wie viel im Weltraum ist. Und das Problem ist,
weil es das erste Problem gibt, gibt es keine Diskussion über das zweite.
Das ist wirklich das Problem heute. Es ist fast unglaublich, darüber nachzudenken.
Ich bin gerade letztens von Amerika nach Deutschland geflogen,
bin hier in München gelandet. Man kann sich vorstellen, dass ein chinesisches
Flugzeug hier landet und sagt, ich sage euch nicht, wo ich bin.
Ich sage euch nicht, wann ich komme, aber ich werde in München landen.
Tatsache ist, das ist absolut gefährlich, es kann nicht sein.
Genau so funktioniert der Raum im Moment.
Wir haben in Amerika die europäische Gemeinde, alle haben Japan.
Wir haben alle unsere Satelliten in einem Verzeichnis. Wir sagen,
wann wir die raustun, was wir tun.
Jeder Launch ... Natürlich, wir sehen, wenn die Chinesen launchen usw.
Aber die Tatsache ist, es gibt im Moment kein internationales Abkommen,
das uns wirklich hilft, mit dem direkt umzugehen. Das Problem ist,
es gibt nicht einen chinesischen Raum und einen europäischen, amerikanischen Raum.
Der Raum gehört allen.
Und wir haben nicht Transparenz.
Das Ganze muss anfangen mit Transparenz.
Ehrlich gesagt, wir haben schon jetzt grosse Probleme. Nicht nur die Astronomen.
Wir haben grosse Probleme. Es gibt gewisse Orbits, wo wir fast nicht mehr reinlaunchen können.
Orbits, die wichtig sind für die Menschheit.
Wir haben grosse Schwierigkeiten und wir müssen unbedingt Fortschritte machen.
Die internationale Gemeinschaft hat keine Lösung dazu gefunden.
Die United Nations Office of Outer Space Affairs, oder wie die heissen,
die Zeitskale von Änderungen oder von Regulationen sind vergleichbar mit geologischen Zeitskalen.
Also mit anderen Worten, etwas das viel schneller, viel effizienter gehen muss,
als wir heute Werkzeuge dafür haben. Das ist wirklich ein grosses Problem und
es wird nachts schlimmer.
Das heisst hier ist im Prinzip die internationale Politik gefragt,
aber der Incentive da wirklich Fortschritte zu erzielen ist derzeit nicht so richtig da.
Genau. Aber es fiel mir einfacher zu verstehen, dass es ein zweites Problem
gibt mit dem ersten zusammen. Es ist klar, die westliche Welt ist führend im
Raum, insbesondere Amerika.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn ich mit einem chinesischen Pass aufgewachsen wäre,
würde mir das auch Sorgen machen. Ich weiss nicht.
Für mich ist es nicht so, dass ich es nicht verstehe.
Aber ich verstehe nicht, dass wir nicht zusammenkommen und das Problem angehen.
Weil der Raum wird nicht mehr nützlich sein, auf der Art und Weise,
wie er sein sollte für die Menschheit.
Wirklich der Menschheit zu dienen, wenn wir das Problem nicht lösen.
Und das wahrscheinlich auch schon recht bald, oder?
Ja, also ich habe das Gefühl, dass es innerhalb der nächsten zehn Jahren geht.
Also wir sind schon jetzt auf Stufe gelb-orange.
Also es geht auf Stufe rot in den nächsten zehn Jahren.
Und diese Sichtweise teilen nicht alle oder es gibt einfach nur eben nicht diesen
Durchbruch für die Politik, sich dieser Problematik auch anzunehmen oder da
Kompromisse zu schließen.
Also wo hakt es sozusagen? Also das grösste Problem,
das ich sehe, ist wirklich, dass es auf der Stufe der Länder,
die viel im Raum dazu beitragen, insbesondere China, dass China bis jetzt nicht an den Tisch kommt.
Also das ist das erste. Und dann, das ist nicht das einzige Problem.
Es gibt dann verschiedene Probleme, die nächste Stufe darunter ist.
Was sind die Regulationen, die wir haben wollen? Also es ist klar,
dass im Moment Starlink hat am meisten Satelliten, also Starlink wird,
es wird so viele Starlink Satelliten geben wie alle anderen Satelliten,
glaube ich, dieses Jahr oder nächstes Jahr.
Seit der gesamten Raumfahrtgeschichte.
Genau. Und ehrlich gesagt, die sind sehr tief. Die Art und Weise,
wie es gemacht ist, ist nicht dumm.
Ich weiss im Detail, wie es gemacht wird. Es ist wirklich gut überlegt,
dass Satelliten, die kaputt gehen, tief fliegen, nicht hoch fliegen.
Weil sie dann halt schnell abgebremst werden und einfach runterfallen.
Genau aus dem Grund.
Und SpaceX hat sich auch Mühe gegeben, die dunkler zu machen.
Ehrlich gesagt waren alle überrascht, wie hell sie sind am Himmel.
Sie sind viel dunkler und haben gewisse Dinge mit Astronomen gearbeitet.
Aber die Tatsache ist, dass es eine Firma gibt, ohne weiteres könnte ich über
fünf andere Firmen sprechen, die auch in den nächsten Jahren hunderte,
wenn nicht tausende von Satelliten rausbringen.
Zwei hatte ich ja schon genannt, Kuiper von Amazon und OneWeb,
die sind auf jeden Fall am Start, aber weitere werden folgen und andere Länder
wollen das wahrscheinlich auch haben,
weil auch dieser Kampf ums Internet, man sieht das jetzt gerade auch mit dem
Konflikt um die Ukraine, da wird das ja auch wieder eine ganz wichtige,
sicherheitsrelevante Infrastruktur werden.
Ja, genau. Drum wird das Problem grösser werden, als es heute ist. Absolut.
Ein verwandtes Problem ist ja generell die Sache mit der Reparatur.
Als es noch das Space Shuttle gab, da hatte man so eine fliegende Werkstatt.
Das war zwar alles sehr teuer, aber hat ja funktioniert.
Hubble, das tolle Teleskop, ist ja überhaupt erst durch so eine Reparaturmission
wieder in Stand gesetzt worden, nachdem es einen Konstruktionsfehler gab,
in dem da so eine Brille aufgesetzt wurde, die ja super funktioniert hat.
Gerade um so die Missionen solcher super teuren und super wichtigen Missionen
wie Hubble zu verlängern, wäre das ja eigentlich ganz wünschenswert.
Hat das noch eine Zukunft solche Reparatur-Missionen in irgendeiner Form zu starten?
Ist so die Robotik und auch generell so die Launcher-Technik und die Kosten,
wie sie sich jetzt abzeichnen, sieht das nach einem viablen Weg aus,
dass man da nochmal hinkommt und solche Geräte repariert bekommt oder zumindest
so große Busse wie der Envisat von der ESA,
die da rumfliegen und leider nicht mehr reagieren, die vielleicht auch wieder
koordiniert zur Erde zu bringen?
Absolut. Schon jetzt gibt es Möglichkeiten,
Satelliten, insbesondere geostationäre Satelliten, zu tanken.
Es wurde schon gemacht, es gab eine Geschichte im letzten Jahr,
als ein geostationärer Satellit getankt wurde während eines Fussballspiels.
Also einen europäischen Fussballspieler über Amerika.
Und er wurde getankt und der Satellit flieg weg und das Fussballspiel wurde nie unterbrochen.
Also während er das Fussballspiel übertragen hat?
Wurde er getankt.
Ah ja.
Ja, absolut. Also das gibt es schon heute.
Das wurde entwickelt aus verschiedenen Gründen, auch für grosse Systeme in Amerika.
Kommerzielle, aber auch andere Systeme. Und wir werden das mehr und mehr brauchen.
Was gebraucht wird, werden robotische Servicing.
Entschuldigung, war das ein geostationärer Satellit?
Ja, das gibt es schon. Wurde schon entwickelt. Wir sprechen nicht so oft darüber,
weil viele der Anwendungen eben nicht so viele sind. Aber die Tatsache ist, es ist öffentlich.
Das gibt es schon. Ich bin so sicher, dass es das gibt.
Für zukünftige Satelliten, für grosse Teleskope werden wir von Anfang an reinbauen.
Wir haben schon gesagt, dass das nächste grosse Teleskop von Anfang an reingebaut wird.
Roman, das wir in 2026, 2027 rausschiessen, das grosse Teleskop,
können wir schon tanken.
Aber jetzt nur für Erdorbit-Missionen.
Für Erdorbit, aber L2, also eineinhalb Millionen Kilometer weg.
Also da, wo jetzt James Webb und Herschel Plank und so weiter rumflogen.
Genau. Wir müssen die Technologie entwickeln. Wir haben der Industrie schon
gesagt, wir wollen das kaufen. Und die Tatsache ist, wenn man geostationär ist,
ist nicht viel mehr Energie.
Das Problem ist mit GPS, man muss sicher stehen, dass wir wissen,
wo das ist innerhalb von ein paar Zentimetern.
Das Letzte, was wir tun wollen, ist eine Kollision zwischen zwei Satelliten
bauen, aber die Tatsache ist, das kommt wirklich und ist einer der guten Gründe.
Es gibt zwei, drei Möglichkeiten.
Das erste ist, Lebenszeit zu verlängern. Das heisst, wir müssen weniger raufschicken.
Das zweite ist, die zu verbessern.
Darum will ich es für die NASA-Wissenschaft tun. Wir wollen das Teleskop wie
ein Teleskop auf Hawaii oder Teneriffa bauen, damit man ein neues Instrument
einbauen kann, wie bei Hubble.
Aber wir wollen es mit Robotern tun.
Das Dritte ist, wenn etwas nicht mehr funktioniert, dass wir es abholen und
runterschicken können.
Etwas, woran wir arbeiten – ich bin nicht mehr bei der NASA,
also ich kann nicht Neuigkeiten geben und so weiter – Aber wir arbeiten mit
einer dieser Privatfirmen, Polaris, die mit SpaceX arbeitet,
um Hubble hochzubringen, 80 Kilometer hochzubringen.
Also wieder so einen Boost zu geben.
Wieder einen Boost zu geben. Und der Grund, warum wir das tun wollen,
ist erstens, es hilft uns, Hubble länger zu halten, aber es gibt uns auch die
Möglichkeit, mit Hubble mehr zu lernen.
Dass wir eben Hubble brauchen können, um Dinge zu flecken und wirklich mit dem wiederzulernen.
Aber jetzt weniger mit Astronauten und Astronauten wie mit Hubble früher,
sondern mehr mit Robotern.
Müsste mit Hubble nicht auch die Gyroskope ausgetauscht werden,
um da die Laufzeit wirklich garantiert zu verlängern?
Was muss ausgegangen werden?
Die Gyroskope müssen noch drei, nur noch im Betrieb von den sechs und wenn einer
noch ausfällt, dann ist alles vorbei.
In meiner Zeit bei der NASA habe ich alles schon analysiert.
Also ich weiss, was wir tun können.
Der erste Schritt ist, dass wir dem Hubble Lebenszeit geben müssen und wir wissen,
was wir tun können. Ja, Gyroskope sind eine der wichtigsten Technologien.
Das Zweite sind Computer. Die Computer haben Probleme.
Wir haben auf einer Seite auf die andere Seite umschalten müssen,
weil die eine Seite quasi so ein Computer sich aufhängt, auf eine Art und Weise mehr als es sollte.
Es gibt zwei, drei andere Probleme, aber wir wissen, was wir tun können.
Das erste ist, dass wir wieder ankoppeln müssen. Wir müssen lernen, wieder anzukoppeln.
Und dann die Frage ist, was können wir tun zusätzlich.
Also wir sind absolut dran.
Jetzt ist leider unsere Zeit heute
begrenzt. Deswegen wollte ich dir jetzt nochmal die Gelegenheit geben,
vielleicht am Schluss noch irgendetwas einzubringen, was ich jetzt noch nicht gefragt habe,
aber was so vielleicht gut passen könnte zu dem, was wir bisher so besprochen
haben, wohin so die Reise geht mit der Raumfahrt, was man noch so erwarten kann,
aber ich lass das jetzt einfach mal offen.
Ja, ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, dass die Raumfahrt ist wirklich eine dieser
Aktivitäten der Menschheit, die wirklich das Beste in den Menschen herausbringen kann.
Zusammenarbeiten, internationale Gemeinschaften, sich auf die Natur zu konzentrieren,
der Erde selber zu helfen, auch mehrere Menschen in den Raum zu bringen,
in einer Art und Weise, wie das früher nicht war.
Wir können gehen, ohne dass wir ein ganzes Leben drauf ausrichten müssen.
Als Astronaut zu arbeiten für mich, das hätte ich nie gemacht.
Fünf Jahre irgendwie zu trainieren, Schrauben anzuziehen im Raum,
für mich baue lieber ein Sattel. Also ich habe viele Freunde,
die Astronauten sind, Astronautinnen auch, und das sind unglaubliche Menschen.
Nichts Kritisches zu dem, aber für mich, wenn ich meine...
Man muss das machen, was man am besten kann.
Für mich die Frage ist, innerhalb der nächsten 15 Jahre können wir Wissenschaftler,
die im Labor stehen, in einen Raum schicken, dass sie für ein Jahr dort arbeiten
können, oder ein paar Monate, um wirklich Experimente zu machen,
so gut wie im Labor da unten.
Ich glaube, die Antwort ist, das wird möglich sein.
Wahrscheinlich innerhalb von zehn Jahren, vielleicht viel kürzer.
Also wirklich Leute, die mit ein paar Monaten Training das tun können.
Und für mich ist das alles möglich. Es gibt viele Dinge. Ja, es gibt Bedrohungen.
Wir müssen die auch im Auge behalten. Und insbesondere die Friedenslage im Raum.
Wie wir mit dem Raum umgehen. Aber auch, wie wir mit dem Raum umgehen bezüglich der Benutzung.
Wirklich das überlegen. Auch auf dem Mond zum Beispiel. Wie werden wir mit dem
Mond umgehen, wenn wir alle dorthin gehen?
Das sind genauso wichtige Fragen wie der Zaun in der Nachbarschaft.
Ich glaube, das ist auch ein ganz klares Bekenntnis zur bemannten Raumfahrt.
Ich glaube, dass Raumfahrt in der Zukunft auch bemannte Raumfahrt sein wird. Es wird beides sein.
Es ist für mich ziemlich einfach, darüber nachzudenken.
Wir haben viel Forschung in den schwierigsten Gebieten auf der Erde.
Vulkane, Antarktika. Es gibt keine Expeditionen ohne Menschen.
Obwohl wir Drohnen haben, die auch die unterstützen, die Menschen sind immer dort.
Und warum? Weil es bessere Forschung ist.
Das wird auch so sein auf dem Mars.
Und es sorgt auch für eine ganz andere emotionale Beteiligung der Menschheit
und die ist natürlich auch wichtig.
Absolut.
Thomas, vielen, vielen Dank. Ich hätte noch stundenlang weiterreden können,
aber die Zeit ist heute leider begrenzt.
Vielleicht führen wir das Gespräch später mal weiter.
Aber ich sage jetzt erstmal vielen Dank für die Ausführung.
Ja, vielen Dank und absolut, wenn wir eine Gelegenheit haben weiter zu sprechen,
tue ich das gerne und alles Beste.
Sehr gut, sehr schön. Und vielen Dank auch fürs Zuhören hier bei ROM-Zeit.
Bald geht es wieder weiter. Tschüss, bis bald.